per questa storia qua devo ringraziare
alcuni miei fan e mia madre ma partiamo
con ordine che vi spiego tutto nei primi
giorni di marzo alcune persone su
twitter inizio alla di m guarda che c'è
un articolo che parla di youtubers su
una rivista e come da tradizione senza
chiedermi un cazzo hanno messo anche me
dentro ed esce fuori che questo articolo
era su focus junior
ebbene sì il focus junior non è ancora
morto e ha deciso di cavalcare l'onda
delle nuove superstar youtuber facendo
appunto un articolo non avendo la
rivista tra le mani vado su internet a
scrivere focus youtuber e ciccia fuori
anche sul sito come diventarono youtuber
parte 1 mini guida facile e veloce su
come aprire un canale youtube e
diventare uno youtuber iniziando da zero
o wow mamma posso finalmente smettere di
friggere patatine ti danno qualche
consiglio tipo individua la tua passione
immagina il tema che vuoi trattare
guarda i canali che ti ispirano e poi ci
sono io con le mani semitrasparenti
conoscete gli hobby
dopo aver fatto per anni recensioni di
film brutti ora ha aperto anche un
canale dove gioca videogame brutti o
antichi tralasciando il fatto che hanno
saltato tutti i video del 2014 cioè
quelli che non sono delle recensioni ma
a quanto pare se io non faccio
recensioni sparisco dalla timeline
temporale da dove gioca videogames
brutti o antichi il piacere sono io toby
e o 100 74 anni nella parte ii invece ti
dicono che la prima cosa da fare è
chiedere il permesso ai vostri genitori
non sognatevi di fare senza mamma e papà
avranno senz'altro qualcosa da dirvi e
come non immaginare solo un dialogo del
genere che inizia col mamma voglio
aprire un canale youtube e finisce col
mamma dove hai trovato quel coltello a
serramanico
ma va beh non è che possiamo darci così
tanto pesante per un sito che
palesemente per bambini e che ha scritto
articoli tipo diventare famosi su
youtube con il proprio cane ea un certo
punto mi chiama mia mamma e mi dice di
aver comprato una rivista dove parlano
di meno
focus junior di marzo in copertina
troviamo fa vj e gli altri gli altri ea
metà rivista troviamo professione
youtuber e poco prima di iniziare
all'articolo possiamo trovare la
vignetta dove c'è un pomodoro una
zucchina e una carota che dicono
youtuber ad una patata l'avete gravità
youtuber perché lei un tubero e quindi
youtuber perché le un tubero e quindi
in questo articolo si parla di molti
youtuber di lorenzo di michelle phan di
chi naldi piedi paghi scottex grampi cat
che ha scritto un libro la mia vita fa
schifo e poi ci sono anche io inizi
caricava video di recensioni esilaranti
suo film poi è passato i videogiochi e
ripeto siccome questo numero di marzo
teoricamente sì sono saltati un intero
anno dove ho fatto vivido ma vabbè cosa
fa ora partecipa al web series più o
meno si pubblicazioni editoriali che
leggermente generico come dire che il
panettiere fa cibo e partecipa a fiere
di videogame di cui scrive anche
recensioni
salve youtubers e benvenuti ad una nuova
recensione la fiera che voglio recensire
oggi è la fiera di videogames comics
caciotta affumicate di trepalle vicino
all'inizio
voi non avete idea di come sia recitata
male scritta peggio è diretta al peggio
di qualsiasi altra fiera che io abbia
mai visto in vita mia oh mio dio aspetta
che metto altre facce buffe in mezzo
così vi faccio ridere
voi non avete idea degli effetti
speciali orripilanti che io ho visti in
quella virali